الموت جوعا يرسلك الى الجنه حتى الان توفي
89 شخصا صدقوا هذه الرساله فما القصه
الحادثه وقعت في كينيا وهي عن جماعه جولد
نيوز انترناشونال التي يراسها الزعيم
بولما كنزي والذي اقنع اتباعه بان الموت
جوعا يرسلهم الى الله مكانزي نفسه يؤمن
بهذه الفكره لانه مقبوض عليه اليوم منذ
الرابع عشر من ابريل وهو يرفض تناول
الطعام او الماء كما احتجز ايضا 14 شخصا
من اعضاء الجماعه 89 جثه وجدتها الشرطه في
غابه شاكاهولا شرق كينيا حيث مقر الكنيسه
وللاسف معظم الجثث من الاطفال وهناك من
وجدوهم احياء يعانون الهزال لكنهم توفوا
في وقت لاحق اما النجون فيصل عددهم الى 34
شخصا وقد ترتفع الوفيات لان الصليب الاحمر
تلقى بلاغات بغياب نحو 200 شخص وزاره
الداخليه وصفت الحادث بانه نقطه تحول في
التهديد الذي يشكله التطرف الديني ووعدت
بانه لن يتكرر مجددا
[موسيقى]